let's review calculating confidence
intervals for proportions so let's say i
have a population and i care about some
proportion let's say i care about the
proportion of folks that are left-handed
i don't know what that is and so i take
a sample of size n and then from that
sample i can calculate a sample
proportion that's why i put that little
hat on top of it it's a sample
proportion that's estimating our true
proportion
now i want to construct a confidence
interval but before i go down the path i
need to actually set up my conditions
for inference make sure that i meet them
and we've done this many times so the
first condition for inference is the
random condition
i need to feel good that this is truly a
random sample from the population the
second one is often known as the normal
condition and that's the condition that
hey in order to feel like the sampling
distribution for the sample proportions
is roughly normal
n
times our sample proportion should be
greater than or equal to 10
and
n times 1 minus our sample proportion
should be greater than or equal to 10.
we've seen that multiple times before
and then the third one is the
independence condition and there's two
ways to meet this
either the individual observations in
our sample should be done with
replacement or if it's not done with
replacement we can feel pretty confident
about this if our sample size is no more
than 10 percent of the size of the
entire population
but let's say that we meet these
conditions for inference what do we do
well we come up we set up a confidence
level
confidence
for our confidence interval that we're
about to construct and let's say we said
it was a 95 confidence level that would
mean that 95 percent of the time that we
went through this exercise the
confidence interval that we get would
actually overlap with the true
population proportion and 95 is actually
a fairly typical one but from that
confidence level you can calculate a
critical value
and the way that you do that you just
look up in a z table once again all of
this is review you would say hey how
many standard deviations above and below
the mean of a normal distribution would
you need to go in order to get say 95
percent that confidence level of the
distribution and now we're ready to
calculate the confidence interval
confidence
interval
it is going to be equal to our sample
proportion
plus or minus our critical value
our critical value
times the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution of the
sample proportion now there is a way to
calculate this exactly if we knew what p
is if we knew what p is this would be
the square root of p times 1 minus p
over n but if we knew what p is we
wouldn't even have to do this business
of constructing confidence intervals so
instead we estimate this we say look the
an estimate of the standard deviation of
the sampling distribution often known as
the standard error an estimate of this
is going to be
the square root of instead of the true
population parameter we could use the
sample proportion so p hat times 1 minus
p hat all of that over n
now the whole reason why i did this this
is covered in much more detail and much
slower in other videos is to see the
parallels between this and a situation
when we're constructing a two sample
confidence interval or z interval for
difference between proportions what am i
talking about
well let's say that you have two
different populations so this is the
first population and it has some true
proportion of the folks that let's say
are left-handed and then there's another
population
so let's call that p2 you know maybe
this is
a freshman in your high school or
college and maybe this is sophomores so
two different populations and you want
to see if there's a difference between
the proportion that are left-handed say
and so
what you could do just like we've done
here is for each of these populations
you will take a sample here we'll call
that n1 and then from that sample you
calculate a sample proportion let's call
that p1
and then from this second population we
do the same thing this is n2 notice n1
and n2 do not have to be the same sample
size that's a common misconception when
doing these things these could be
different sample sizes and then from
that sample you calculate the sample
proportion now after you do that you
would want to check your conditions for
inference and it turns out that the
conditions for inference would be
exactly the same do both of these
samples meet the random condition do
both of these samples meet the normal
condition and do both of these samples
meet the independence condition and if
both samples meet these conditions for
inference then we would have to
calculate our critical value and you
would do it the exact same way i'll just
write it down again so first you need to
check all of these then you would take
your confidence level
confidence
level
and from that get a critical z
and then you're ready to say what your
confidence interval is going to be so
your
confidence confidence
interval
for
p1
minus p2 so it's a confidence interval
for the difference between these true
population
proportions
that is going to be equal to the
difference between your sample
proportions
so
p hat 1
minus p hat 2
p hat 2
plus or minus
plus or minus your critical value right
over here
times
the
standard deviation of the sampling
distribution of the difference between
the sample proportions
so it would be p
hat 1
minus
p hat 2.
and so we already know how to calculate
this how to calculate this how to
calculate this how do we calculate that
well i will just give you the formula
first but then we just have to
appreciate that this just comes out of
the properties of standard deviations
and variances
that we have studied in the past
so the standard
deviation
of the sampling distribution of the
difference between the sample
proportions it is a mouthful
this is going to be approximately equal
to
approximately equal to the square root
of
p hat 1 times 1 minus p hat 1
over n 1
plus
p hat 2 times 1 minus p hat 2
over
n 2.
and then you put that there you have
constructed your confidence interval and
once again how would you interpret that
well let's say your confidence level is
ninety percent
and from that you're able to construct
this confidence interval that would mean
that ninety percent of the time that you
go through this exercise your confidence
interval would overlap with the true
difference between these population
parameters the true difference between
these population proportions
now where did this thing come from well
you might notice some similarities here
this part over here
is an estimate or it's approximately
equal to
the variance of the sampling
distribution of the sample proportion
for our first population
and then this right over here
once again is approximately going to be
equal to the variance of the sampling
distribution for the sample proportions
for this population for p2
how did i know that well look if this is
approximately the standard deviation you
square that you approximately get the
variance and so the big takeaway is is
that the variance for the sampling
distribution of the difference is just
the sum of the variances of each of
those sampling distributions that's a
lot of big mouthful i know it can get
confusing but hopefully that makes sense
and that's where this formula comes from
and so it's really not that much more to
remember in the next few videos we're
going to do many more examples both
looking at these conditions and
calculating confidence intervals and
critical values